we begin this hour with some relatively
good news connected to the latest covet
surge across the country even though the
u.s set a new one-day record yesterday
with nearly half a million new cases the
cdc says hospitalizations and deaths are
lower than they were in previous surges
the u.s has averaged more than 300
thousand new cases a day over the past
week nikki batista is outside an
emergency room in new york city this
looks like good news nikki but those
case numbers still out of control
still out of control jamie good morning
covid continues to shatter records here
in new york the state hit a new daily
record of just over 74 thousand positive
tests yesterday and hospitalizations are
the highest they've been since last
winter here in new york city the seven
day moving average of positive cases hit
a new record of nearly 30 thousand
people and other states are also seeing
record-breaking levels new jersey
reported a new pandemic high of about 27
thousand daily cases florida reached a
new daily high with nearly 60 thousand
cases and experts warned that the
holiday travel and gatherings may just
make these coveted numbers continue to
go up jamie his numbers don't account
for those at-home tests either nikki
thank you